you got a question yeah
did I ever go back to the restaurant so
he's referring to I I happen to just
my pants on my first date with my
wife
[Music]
somebody was like it's when they asked
me that like when was the second date I
was like she took a couple days to think
it over I'm sure quick little briefing
on what happened we were out I had been
out the night before and I've been
drinking a lot I used to drink I don't
drink anymore I found out that I make
bad life decisions when I drink
you might be here with one of yours
tonight I don't know
so
you laughed a little too hard at that
one okay all right so so I was out with
her and my stomach was a little
up but I had talked to her on the phone
I really liked her and I didn't want to
I didn't want to not show up
and so I I felt a sneeze coming on
and I am like a loud mouth
sneezer I didn't want to scare her on
her first date so I plug my nose
and when I plug my nose my sneeze came
out my
it was a straight it was a butthole
sneeze is what it was
and she for sure noticed that something
was wrong because I'm sure my face was
and she said something like
yeah it's pretty magnificent night I
feel it too I'm like
I hope you don't feel this that would be
way more powerful than I thought it was
and um I didn't know what to do man
because I had never met this girl and I
had
in my pants
and so I was like I
I don't know what to do I was as I was
thinking about it she said to me she
goes hey I gotta use the restroom and I
was like you got to use the restroom
so when you shoot to the bathroom you
know look here are the two options leave
which was the first thought but I it
wasn't like a little
everyone when I walked out everyone
would have known that I had in my
pants
so I was like I just gotta tell her
I gotta tell her and just hope she's a
human you know
so she sits down and I go hey
she goes yeah
I go I gotta tell you something
she goes you can tell me anything
and I said well we're about to find out
aren't we
I just I just said
I myself
this is how I knew I was going to marry
her dude she looked me dead in the eye
and she goes I knew it
she was like I'm sitting two feet away
from you you don't think I could smell
that you have in your pants
everybody in this section knows you have
in your pants and I was like what
the guy sitting next to me was like yeah
dude when are you leaving
so yeah first date yeah I went back I'm
gonna tell you so right now I asked her
I said hey this is like our fourth day I
go you want to go to dinner she goes
yeah
I go you want to go back to that place
where I myself
she goes yeah I never did get to finish
my meal